this video is brought to you by raycon i
haven't said this in a while but here it
goes berserk's golden age arc is the
best arc i've read easily since one
piece and to be perfectly honest might
be the best arc i've ever read it is
preposterously good to put it into
perspective i normally set aside about
four days to read and digest all the
material i cover in a single video but
with this arc i picked it up and
suddenly i lost 10 hours of my life
because i read almost all of it in one
sitting i didn't drink water i didn't
stand up and i didn't eat dare i say
berserk's golden age arc is perfect last
time i covered the black swordsman arc
and while i really liked it comparing
that to this arc is like comparing
corcus to griffith
but enough introductions today i'm
taking my first step into an arc many
refer to as the greatest arc in all of
manga and let me tell you in advance it
holds up to such a moniker i'm toying up
mark and today i'm covering the first
half of the golden age arc
[Music]
[Music]
surging back into the past with the
blink of an eye we come to learn exactly
how gutz became the person he is today
outlining a chilling tale dealing with
powerful themes of abuse relationships
and one's own struggle to find their
place in the world this story is a work
of art that while passionate in its
creation and telling paints its most
vibrant colors not with traditional
tools but with the more deviant
grotesque and contorted aspects of its
subject matter humanity holding a mirror
up to society as we view the early life
of our main hero creating moments where
i left for my seat with joy grabbed this
comically sized book and squeezed it but
above all else it captured my attention
from chapter one and never let go it's
difficult to know where to start with
this review as there's an incredible
amount to discuss and analyze but i
think the best place to start this
review is chronologically with the
introduction of guts to this big
and bad world
the prologue the material covered in
this section details guts's early
childhood in hindsight while this can be
seen as the prologue to the eventual
epic that begins once griffith arrives
much like our own childhood many of the
events in this portion some mundane and
other shocking help aid us in better
empathizing and understanding berserk's
characters when you start from the
beginning of a character's life like
this i've discovered it offers many
ideal opportunities for elegant and
telling pieces of dialogue specifically
because we've already spent a
considerable amount of time with the
character in his later life forcing the
explicit and even the subtly implicit
moments to stand out to us all the more
for instance something i found
interesting right off the bat concerning
golden age was that for a decent amount
of its introduction guts doesn't say
anything in fact his first piece of
dialogue in this arc comes long after he
should be able to speak as a child and
it's not something he offers without
antagonization growing up in a band of
mercs his mother after dying and his
only father figure abusive in the middle
of a sword training session the
onlookers in the band jeer why don't you
use a sword more your size and after
being thrown to the floor guts
passionately exclaims
no dotted throughout this first chapter
covering his life from birth to nine
years of age were offered small windows
into intimate and character-defining
moments in his life like this some as
explicit as his proclivity for large
weaponry poetically gripping them
tightly for security amidst the harsh
and damaging upbringing or other more
subtle familiar actions like choosing to
be there for his mom when she was
passing away even from that young of an
age he was willing to take the more
difficult option because
it meant something to someone he cared
for that really paints all of this
introduction the events that he endures
before the age of 10 are painfully human
with some of the absolute worst aspects
of our species laid to bear it is
horrific what happens to this child to
say the least and helps inform me how he
sees the world in the present day i've
certainly had times where as a child
i've been convinced of one thing that an
adult has said and has successfully
concealed the truth and as we look on
almost exclusively through guts's point
of view after having been told gambino
his father figure sold him off for the
night authorizing this heinous act it
makes their encounter afterwards all the
more unsettling and from a narrative
point of view
interesting the most interesting aspect
of this prologue comes through the
dissection and destruction of the only
relationship guts has in gambino
something i try to reliably do as a
reader is to constantly be aware of what
point of view i'm seeing certain events
through what we're implicitly told can
be as important or more important than
explicit information particularly when
it comes to coloring different
characters there are at least two
significant events where we are shown
that gambino is directly involved on the
page a particular training session with
guts and his drunken attempted murder of
the young man to cap things off gambino
is cruel emotionally bankrupt and he's
all guts has in the world with his only
substantial interactions coming by way
of battle or training for battle we see
firsthand why swords and battle are the
coping mechanisms guts has shown a
preference for and as guts gets revenge
on his attacker gambino loses his leg
and the years drift on by until we hit
the climax to this prologue a climax
that hit like a train drunk he
eventually admits that he did accept
payment for the heinous act committed
unto guts earlier in his life admission
that he hates him and in that same
breath attacks guts launching forward
with his sword
[Music]
running for his life terrified and after
suffering a tremendous fall the chaotic
nature of this manga finally relents
unveiling panels around these quiet
intimate moments that are nothing short
of breathtaking don't get me wrong i
love miura's big action set pieces too
but there's nothing i enjoy more than
his tranquil pieces more personal
moments gut shares with us as readers
and throughout this arc my favorite
illustrations from miura are not the
action heavy or horrific renderings of
the epic or fierce they aren't the
shocking or the scaring but instead the
tranquil the peaceful beauty that can be
found amidst the most chaotic of
misfortunes
band of the falcon
this is it the section were introduced
to griffith and the group of adolescent
mercenaries he leads after a dominant
performance in a village earning him
some serious coin guts begins making his
way out of town when he's attacked by a
group of griffith's crew members this is
the inciting incident that leads guts
and griffith down one of the most
interesting journeys i've experienced in
manga it seems at this point there's a
clear pecking order with kaska being the
number two to griffith's clear and far
away number one this is a leader while
young is seen almost as a god by those
in his dead and once guts wakes up
partially recovered from his previous
injuries courtesy of griffith himself we
get a short tour around the camp getting
introduced to the rest of the band but
all of that is small potatoes compared
to this
guts versus griffith the fight that
takes place between griffith and guts is
spectacular beyond measure and i will be
using it to structure this particular
review from a design point of view i
love how these two characters are
effectively polar opposites of each
other guts is rough around the ages
emotional with dark features while
griffith is calm and smooth with fair
delicate features you can tell
everything you need to know about these
two characters just by looking at their
swords and how they wield them guts with
two hands attacks aggressively charging
forward while griffith parries the
oncoming attacks from guts while only
using one hand on his weapon and when it
comes to the makeup of their blades
we're greeted with even more information
guts uses a large hunk of iron while
griffith a far more dignified and
modestly sized blade with some flashy
trimming on the hilt i love attention to
details like this it's a superbly
stunning design everything from their
opposing colored clothes to their hair
and even their faces that they make
during the fight guts's grimace
contrasted heavily by the composed and
almost emotionless expression of
griffith from a visual perspective this
fight even in its opening exchanges has
more working in its favor than so so
many others and given that i know what
the relationship amounts to later seeing
this first proper clash i was extremely
invested and i haven't even mentioned
the best part of the fight the actual
fight this altercation was made with the
understanding that if guts kills
griffith he goes free and if griffith
wins then guts will be his understanding
these consequences watching as griffith
expertly evades and makes guts look like
an amateur was nerve-racking but no
matter how much griffith pushes guts
guts would always dig even deeper and
never said die this comes to a head
however when after a massive swing of
his sword griffith composed as ever
leaps onto gutz's blade having closed
the distance and placed himself in a
victorious position blade pointed
squarely at the throat of guts he asks
forgot to surrender and he refuses ever
defiant he declares i'll show you how
mouths should be used in a fight this
was the single most cathartic moment in
the manga that i've experienced so far
watching as griffith's holier than thou
ass was thrown to the ground with guts
laying a few good hits into boot this
only further bonded me to the tenacious
and sympathetic personality that is
guts of berserk the dialogue in this
section is spectacular with griffith at
one point holding up guts's sword saying
it's an amazing sword i could never
wield it if we want to for a second
speak thematically this could mean a
number of things but because the sword
represents guts's only security against
the darkness in his mind then perhaps
what griffith means or what it can be
interpreted as thematically here is
griffith may not have shared a similar
past and therefore can't wield such a
burdensome weapon with even scenes that
take place as early in his life coming
with familiar lines like the way you
fight it's almost as though you're
gambling on your own life this fight
it honestly had everything from stakes
an audience can get behind compelling
character writing making in character
decisions and the best artwork and
framing the series has shown me yet this
was some top tier stuff climaxing with a
telling and thematically resonant
declaration from griffith once he
outmaneuvers and takes guts out now
you belong to me
the aftermath once the agreement was
made guts became an acting member of
this young band of mercs doing
exceptionally well in his first outing
with the group earning their respect
after the trouble he caused initially
there's a scene that takes place atop
the castle tower that i'd like to
address and i might be reading into it a
little much but i'm a big fan of these
quiet character moments and there might
be something worth reading into in this
scene right after his first day making a
splash a party is held for guts in his
honor reluctant to join in even when
dragged down he always feels most
comfortable when he's left alone
oftentimes in the past even when he
first picked up by this group he sits
with his back to something and his sword
held closely in this instance guts
chooses to sit atop the castle in a
similar fashion but what really caught
my attention more than anything else was
this pose he struck the morning after
sting atop the castle talking to judo
this is a strange pose and from a body
language point of view it makes sense
for him to take this guarded position
considering the subject matter they're
covering in this conversation is a
little personal but i think it could
mean a little more than that he's
covering a specific part of his face
around his nose the scar that lingers
and was etched onto his character design
was given to him by his abusive father
figure after he lashed out at him i
wonder if perhaps miura drew guts in
this scene with judo touching his scar
because unlike the place where he grew
up yearning for something somewhere to
call home in this band of young
mercenaries he might actually find
family in his mind he feels like he
perhaps might have something here and
once the subject turns to griffith again
he immediately clutches his sword once
more to end things the chapter and
glimpse of this time period in gutz's
life comes to a close in a rather
remarkable way with him happy after
achieving a believable friendship now
with some select members of the group
and with him starting to on some level
bring his walls down guts still an
adolescent now in command of his own
small group can look into the future
optimistically perhaps but i'd be remiss
if i didn't mention one final aspect of
this section that caught my attention
that i think is majorly important moving
forward the declaration griffith made
citing that he wants a kingdom and that
guts belongs to him having read the
prior material one of the themes
emphasized and explored in great detail
was that of freedom and the lengths one
would go specifically guts to retain
that freedom during the black swordsman
arc guts valued freedom above all else
and i don't think i need to be a genius
to put two and two together here in this
instance something's gonna happen
i wouldn't consider myself an audiophile
but i know what sounds good to me and my
raikons are the best earbuds i own i'm
serious i say that not from a position
of spec versus spec but instead from how
easy they are to use in my everyday life
i'm super busy most of the time but i
have two adorable dogs that need a walk
daily so whenever i'm forced to leave my
workstation i'll normally queue up some
video essays and similar subject matter
to what i'm currently working on and
make voice memos to myself using my
raikon's built-in mic with no wires it's
just so much more convenient for all the
different situations i use them in for
example at night i like to relax in bed
while listening to a podcast and not
having wires around my chin and arms as
i get comfortable frees me from the
worry of rolling over and accidentally
ripping them out of my ears since they
come with a bunch of gel tips you'll be
able to get a nice comfy snug fit
tailored to your ear shape that won't
fall out with an astonishing 32 hours of
battery life i've actually never had to
charge them since i got them last month
they are so damn good and all at half
the price of other audio brands so if
these sound good to you and you want to
support my channel then check the link
in the description or go to buy raycon
dot com slash not mark to get 15 off
your raikon purchase today with a 45 day
free return policy you can try them
yourself risk free
all right who's gonna jerk me off
[Applause]
now it's about at this time in my script
writing process i realized that if i
were to proceed like this through the
events of the story the video in
question would be about 90 minutes long
and i would be repeating myself ad
nauseum and due to this fact i was faced
with a difficult decision to make how
should i structure this how do i tackle
this massive story and then i asked
myself what were the most important
aspects of this story and my answer the
characters
something i think is important to
mention at this point is that i
recognize the significance of nosferatu
zod the battle for doldry and the
absence of demonic creatures throughout
this review of the story however having
come from the black swordsman arc set
after this we saw all sorts of strange
creatures one after another the
significance of these aspects or lack
thereof in this story i thought would be
better suited for the second part of
this golden age review as i think
dividing zod's prophecy between two
videos could get a little messy so rest
assured i will be talking about that in
the next berserk review from this point
on i'd like to go a little more abstract
with my approach to this review and talk
specifically about the themes and
dynamics of different characters that
drive this section of the story towards
its conclusion starting with griffith
griffith is an astonishingly brilliant
character to structure this entire story
around as i mentioned before in my
dissection of his and guts's first jewel
he is pitch perfect in both how he's
handled and what he says in this story
if ever i saw a character whose dynamic
gave a particular story everything they
possibly could griffith would fit that
billing to a t the means with which
miura introduces and builds this
character up over the course of the
narrative is not only enjoyable but also
creates suspense in a sense it's
difficult to discuss griffith in any
meaningful capacity without referring to
his effect on other people in the
greater story stories are after all
normally about conflict typically
between two or more characters but
griffith more so than any character in
this story has the makeup of his
character delivered almost exclusively
through how he speaks and how others
view him throughout the entirety of this
story that i've read for the purposes of
this video from the beginning to the
morning of departure chapter 3 virtually
no internal dialogue is given to us as
readers from griffith's perspective now
many of you at this point might be
saying so who cares if we don't see his
internal yammerings what does that
matter well it matters primarily because
this arc deals with the interpersonal
relationships between many different
characters many of which include
griffith as a primary player and without
his internal monologue to let us as
viewers into understanding what he's
honestly thinking it achieves elegantly
and precisely just the right dynamic
that allows this arc to work as well as
it does it gives us all the information
we need but doesn't tell us what to do
with that information off the back of
the prologue the casterone in guts
explodes as we get to know the band of
the hawk through the likes of casca judo
corcus pippin rickard etc but notice how
i didn't mention griffith while griffith
plays an enormous role in the success of
this arc we don't really at any point
get to know him like we do the other
characters and certainly not in the same
level as we do with the likes of casca
and guts we do receive quiet moments
with just griffith and guts from time to
time but the only reason i'm sure of
those instances is due to griffith
scarcity in the narrative let's take
these scenes for example there are a
number of scenes where guts and griffith
talk and where griffith even talks with
others in his follow but we never see
what he's actually thinking we only ever
really receive speculation from guts and
with increasing frequency the larger
group constantly praising griffith at
first as a great leader a warrior until
he reaches goal after goal after goal in
which people then start to refer to him
as otherworldly or godlike and this
positioning the narrative places
griffith in the story is primarily what
drives the suspense moving forward we
know what griffith wants we know what
his goal is and we know what he's
willing to do to achieve these ends but
we have no idea what he's really
thinking that's what makes this scene
from the assassin chapter so interesting
to me in essence it's a small portion of
story centered around general julius's
jealousy of the newly appointed griffith
and as has been the case with many of
the other stories in this arc both
griffith and guts play leading roles
there's an entire panel dedicated to the
conflict in guts's mind and in fittingly
poetic fashion at the chapter's climax
having been assigned by griffith to kill
those that would do him harm in addition
to killing his target and the slimy
general julius he also kills julius's
son following the secondary order of
leaving no witnesses now he didn't know
that this was a kid let alone his when
he killed him but it was a magnificent
example of guts mindlessly following
someone because he believed in him
perhaps more than anyone else in the
world which makes you wonder would he
have done anything he asked and if
that's true then has guts really sold
his soul to this man griffith completely
does he really belong to him was what
griffith said when he won the jewel
entirely true then aside from the
clearly morally reprehensible acts guts
is committing on his allies behalf
where's this sense of conflict we feel
in the story coming from well throughout
this story we felt god's gravitate
towards this group reluctantly we felt
the sense of family begin to foster
within him as well as the comrades he
goes into battle with in battles with
terrifying monsters we've seen griffith
put his life on the line time and again
in the name of saving guts from certain
death with him saying two guts his face
do i need a reason each time i put
myself in harm's way for your sake and
now after climbing out of the sewer like
a rat
leaving a trail of death in his wake
guts looking to speak with what he would
consider a friend stands at the base of
a large staircase as both him and casca
watch on as griffith sitting atop a
stairs out of reach discusses philosophy
with the princess he's courting ending
with the most biting quote of all
highlighting how single-minded he is in
his vision his conquest and never-ending
pursues to his one goal of his when
asked directly about his friends or
troop he says something to the princess
that sets the wheels in motion for what
will become his downfall in this section
of the story he says they are excellent
troops together we have faced death so
many times they are valuable comrades
devoting themselves to the dream i
envision but to me a friend is something
else someone who would never depend upon
another's dream someone who wouldn't be
compelled by anyone but would determine
and pursue his own reason to live and
should anyone trample that dream he
would oppose him body and soul even if
the threat were me myself what i think a
friend is is one who is my equal as
readers having been forced to contend
with the moral ambiguity of the main
character's violent actions knowing full
well he wishes for a relationship with
griffith and knowing that he didn't
enjoy doing what he did that night we
have to watch guts hear digest and
understand that statement from griffith
encapsulated beautifully and as
succinctly as anything i've seen by the
following page highlighting just how
many levels of difference there are both
physically and figuratively between
those two characters the hired assassin
fresh from the sewer acting on someone
else's behalf without question and the
clean and dignified visionary who
pursues with unwavering focus towards
his ultimate dream such poetry we do not
normally see in manga and now
we have direct conflict spawning from a
desire born from guts's childhood and
trauma what an astonishingly great scene
there's absolutely more i want to
discuss regarding this character but for
now let's move on to another for a brief
moment kaska kaska is the third spoke on
this narrative wheel alongside guts and
griffith with respect to guts and
griffiths she represents gutz's
relationship with the band of the hawk
acts as a bridge to griffith during
numerous conversations for guts and
perhaps most crucially she represents
and highlights how the broader band of
the hawk and all who fall under
griffith's spell praise adulate and
glorify him creating a man bigger than
legend itself further serving and
leaning into the composed deification
for lack of a better term that griffith
seems to want to promote around him
while and this is my speculation
leveraging the trauma and yearning for
acceptance these forgotten toys of the
wider berserk world cry out for in his
stead clearly as made evident by the
contents of this video review berserk
and more specifically this arc is
centered around two characters in
griffith and guts however there's a
fascinating section of this story which
allows kaska to take center stage and to
no longer play the seldom scene
secondary character role she has been
following up until this point it all
begins in the day of the big battle
against the white whale knights and as a
quick aside every action this band takes
is to the end of elevating not only
themselves but primarily griffith as he
works his way from lowly commoner to
leader of a mercenary group to a nice to
a general and so on and so forth and
during the events of this section we are
very much entrenched in that struggle
for elevation and promotion one of the
most significant themes following the
character of kaska is one of acceptance
tying wonderfully into guts's sense of
worthlessness she now during this
significant battle starts to find sudden
difficulty due to her own natural
biological complications that set her
apart from this old-fashioned world of
men reminding her that despite her
decision to live like a man there are
some things that can't be avoided and
this same aspect offer leads to guts
someone who's constantly nagging and
poking fun at her for being a girl
however thanks to the time they spend
together he soon realizes and grows to
appreciate and admire how much more
difficult and tough it must be to be a
woman warrior in this instance citing
her as above all the other weaklings at
the reception following the battle
showing a true sign of respect on his
behalf their budding relationship
platonic or otherwise for me was a
phenomenal secondary plot thread which
contrasts her extreme and limitless
admiration for griffith with her natural
and organic relationship with guts the
history that's unearthed concerning her
past as well as the bond she reluctantly
forms with a person she at one point
hated for reasons i'll get into in just
a sec guts was both symbolically
beautiful as all miura works normally
are but it also illuminated a dynamic
that i wasn't aware of being one of the
main characters involved in guts's
recruiting we get to see her side of the
story as she admits to at one point in
time hating guts bringing to light the
reason behind her constant frustrations
and anger towards him over the years
revealing a damaging backstory and
unhealthy admiration for griffith and a
lack of appreciation for guts as well as
those around her by extension in essence
i felt as though while reading these
chapters the more casca got to know and
interact with guts the more the two of
them gained the deeper understanding of
themselves the more deeper appreciation
and empathy for each other they felt
placed in high-risk scenarios as guts
single-handedly slaughters 100 men all
by himself in the name of buying her
time and to get help but also for
another reason i want to touch on in
just a sec once they return to the site
where she last saw guts fighting for his
life we see bodies strewn across the
land as guts holding himself up with the
help of a tree and his trusty sword
stands victorious there have been a
number of instances throughout the story
where guts has run into trouble on his
own causing griffith to put his life on
the line for his sake leading to casca's
hatred for how careless guts can be and
jealousy as to why she can't be cared
for like that by griffith after the
entire outing takes place and resolves
itself she gets what she wanted for
griffith to outwardly state that she is
a valued member and while she does get
that we as readers also see firsthand
that despite griffith having had nothing
to do with this achievement from guts
despite guts getting praised for his
monumentous undertaking others still use
this as an opportunity to highlight how
amazing griffith is in comparison if
guts is this good imagine how amazing
griffith could be this has been
something that's been alluded to
numerous times and while i was aware of
it this was the moment it cemented for
me my feelings on the griffith character
campfire of dreams
campfire of dreams is my favorite
chapter in all of the manga that i've
read so far this is the single most
touching and spectacularly beautiful
chapter i think i've ever read in my
life all the while highlighting exactly
what it is about the story that makes it
so special to me there's no fighting
there's no dynamic action sequences
there's no violence it's just a quiet
moment two friends share from a familiar
distance to the night's festivities as
guts for what feels like the first time
decides to speak his mind and let
someone else in and know how he feels he
begins revealing how he wasn't fighting
back there to protect her against those
100 enemies but instead did so in
essence because it's who he thinks he is
it's what comes naturally and highlights
how he has nothing else in his life he
admires kaska and griffith for feeling
so strongly about their dreams and that
due to the discrepancy between them he
feels alienated even when looking down
at all the individual lights painted
across the land in his honor his dream
whether he wants it to be or not isn't
here with these people and taking what
griffith said to heart he wants to fight
tooth and nail to find something he can
live to die for much like the rest of
this arc it's a 10 out of 10 but because
it resonated with me so powerfully i
needed to dedicate a small bit of this
video's run time to it but the main
takeaway guts is leaving and it'll be
after the next campaign the morning
departure this is a special section of
storytelling for me and figuring out a
way to effectively describe what i felt
while reading has been the cause for
many redrafts of this particular video
essays review there have been certain
iconic scenes i've read through that
have taken my breath away whether it be
through childhood or my adult life i've
looked back at all of these in
retrospect and was able to on some level
figure out how they in fact pulled off
what made them so special to me and what
makes this particular scene all the more
impactful for me anyway is that despite
the largest and most impressive battle
taking place in the form of the battle
to claim tudor stronghold the battle
while impressive and yet again
containing many story beats concerning
guts kaska and griffith respectively it
is but a footnote in my mind compared to
one of the single best rematches in all
of japanese storytelling that i've seen
personally guts versus griffith round
two i think for me what made this
particular encounter so earth-shattering
came in two waves the first being the
least impressive narrative so let's get
that out of the way first up until this
point there has been a considerable and
measured approach taken when comparing
and growing the relationships between
guts and griffith the first major
confrontation between them came about at
a time when guts was much younger less
experienced and not to mention injured
however this was not much mentioned
beyond one or two passing comments
acknowledging that additionally over the
course of the time they spent together
griffith and guts haven't exactly been
short in time spent together alone on
the page sharing moments of levity as
well as deep contemplation with guts
very clearly acting as someone griffith
can confide in however and this has been
made evident since the very beginning
griffith isn't a normal person in this
story with not a single individual
seeing him as someone that they can
build a meaningful relationship with
he's always on another level which
brings me to my favorite aspect of this
story nothing is explicitly told to us
we are left to infer for ourselves what
the relationships are or are not who is
connected to reality and who isn't casca
idolizes griffith she wishes to quote be
his sword meaning that she wants to be
the best warrior she can so that when
the time comes she can be what griffith
needs her to be in combat to defend him
in addition to that practically every
single sentence a character utters in
this story concerning griffith holds him
in the same regard as a deity in
addition to every single last plot
element of the story being told created
with the express purpose of elevating or
protecting griffith standing helping him
to reach his overall goal of ruler which
conflicted magnificently with the
character of guts having grown to be a
mountain of a man and having grown
closer to griffith than he was with any
of the others up until now maybe
excluding caska for him to be confronted
with the notion that yet again he's
worthless compared to him and that
griffith has been using him to meet his
end all this time it must be a bitter
reality to come to terms with and when
guts decides to leave quote once again
is thrown out by griffith you belong to
me this is his mask off moment at least
for me a moment that signifies that
while everything has developed over the
last three years from their status to
their interpersonal relationships as
soldiers and comrades griffith is still
very much the exact same person who said
those words that day which brings me to
something i noticed about the dialogue
and the visuals during this section the
jewel that takes place isn't necessarily
what impresses me about this section but
the swirling of doubt in my mind that
took place during it i was ridiculously
nervous for guts during his lead up for
the first swing but now looking back i
realized that i had no reason to this is
the very first time we are as readers
allowed to see into griffith's thought
process unabated for a consistent amount
of time which allows us to see his
actual thoughts on a broader subject
unlike the first encounter we do not see
anything from guts's point of view
everything is from griffiths from the
commentary the strategy he's looking to
employ to how he's evaluating the
situation whether an environment it is
ridiculously thorough as we experience
firsthand how comprehensive and
contemplative the proficient griffith is
being bolstered in part in my mind by
the constant praise he's received all
the time leading up to this moment in my
mind he's better than guts and when the
swing does come down so too does the
world griffith has made crumble visually
i don't think i need to explain what
makes this spectacular so i'll just
dance across my favorite aspects of it
quickly the mindset of gods is a total
opposite compared to their last with his
facial expressions and his positioning
in many panels reflecting that reality
guts now pictured higher than the once
more domineering griffith painted all
across the backdrop of a sun rising anew
symbolizing a fresh start on the morning
snow the shock that floods across
griffith's face as he drops to his knees
in utter despair when faced with the
sudden reality of his situation was
massively satisfying gutz is more
powerful than griffith he's leaving and
griffith needs him i want to make clear
right now that i have absolutely zero
idea as to how this story arc will
complete but i have a feeling that
despite the horrific stuff i've seen so
far i've seen nothing yet throughout
what i've read so far i've seen in this
material griffith will do just about
anything to give himself what he needs
to succeed and i don't think he would
have made it this far if something like
this was going to stop him he's going to
retaliate but i have no idea how next
time i'll cover that this is as i've
said the best arc i've read in at least
a year and i can't wait to see how it
concludes when i finish it will i
consider it the best arc i've ever read
find out next time but until then i've
been told enough mark thank you all so
much for watching
and i'll see you all next time
[Music]
[Music]
also
[Music]